when he's not there to look after you
who's looking after you I make sure but
I've got a man so any decision I might
even meet for me being on the podcast I
wouldn't be here if it wasn't for him
because before I decided to come on the
podcast
I ask his permission people I think
that's really strange I said what is
your permission would you think about it
this is what I'm gonna do and there's
certain things he didn't like so I told
Pearl you know what I can't do this I
can't do that I can't do whatever and
then we came to a conclusion but the
final decision is always his and I trust
him with it because he'll always have my
best interests at heart I'm a trained
mechanic